5 gehen soll alle rekorde brechen bis zu
1000 mal mehr daten sollen übertragen
werden können möglich wird eine
reaktionsgeschwindigkeit von nicht
einmal mehr einer millisekunde und die
zahl der verbundenen geräte soll sich
gleich darauf in sachen wahnsinn doch
löst 5g krebs aus schaden 5g den
männlichen samen und ignorieren die eu
regierungen diese gefahren krieg zum
science fiction liegen täglich
faszinierende songs videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen die macht war sie
alles möglich fabriken die vollständig
durch roboter betrieben werden können
kühlschränke die mitdenken oder auch
autos die in echtzeit kommunizieren
alles vernetzt und die europäische union
ist sich sicher dass der ausbau von 5 g
zitat entscheidend für die weltweite
wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist aber nicht nur
für die industrie ist 5g eine super
spannende sache sondern auch für uns die
verbraucher mit 5 g könnte man einen
film rund 600 mal schneller laden als
mit dem dessen dsl anschluss um es noch
einmal deutlich zu machen 10 gigabit pro
sekunde also 10.000 megabit pro sekunde
soll die übertragungsbandbreite des
neuen mobilfunkstandards 5g sein
das sind wirklich unvorstellbaren
geschwindigkeiten denn das höchste der
gefühle sind bei den derzeitigen lte
netzen im regelbetrieb 300 mbit und die
meisten smartphone nutzer haben gerade
mal tarif für mit maximal 50 mbit 5d
wird also alles bisherige mit abstand in
den schatten stellen doch bei all den
positiven meldungen reist auch die
kritik an fünf gehen nicht ab denn
strahlung ist für viele menschen extrem
unheimlich wir können sie nicht sehen
fühlen oder höher
aber wir wissen alle dass sie in der
lage ist energie zu übertragen und im
gewebe einzubringen und so könnte 5g
vielleicht unser gesundheitsschaden es
gibt zahlreiche studien die darauf
hindeuten dass elektromagnetische
strahlung in höheren frequenzbereichen
umwelt und gesundheitsschädlich sein
könnte und so haben rund 100.000
menschen einen appell unterzeichnet in
dem unter anderem auch mehr als 500
naturwissenschaftler und
naturwissenschaftlerinnen fordern den
ausbau der 5g technik zu stoppen
demnach drohen mit der implementierung
von 5 g
ernste irreversiblen konsequenzen für
den menschen der umweltpolitiker ernst
ulrich von weizsäcker ist auch dabei wir
wissen nicht sicher ob die mobile
datenübertragungstechnik gesundheitliche
risiken mit sich bringt aber wir können
es auch noch nicht ausschließen und so
sei die politik gefordert sich ernsthaft
mit dem möglichen gesundheitsrisiken
auseinanderzusetzen und zwar im vorfeld
fest steht forschungsteams beschäftigen
sich schon seit jahren mit dem thema
doch konsens darüber wie
gesundheitsschädlich fünf die wirklich
ist besteht noch lange nicht im
gegenteil
die wissenschaft ist über die frage
zutiefst zerstritten es gibt unzählige
wissenschaftliche studien zum thema
doch wie sind deren ergebnisse zu
bewerten genau das ist die große frage
wie bei pixum science fiction hatten ja
vor einiger zeit schon einmal über eine
spannende studie zum thema berichtet
dort waren ratten mit konzentrierten
mobilfunkstrahlen bestrahlt worden und
es gab positive und negative folgen die
bedingung des experiments waren auch
sehr speziell
das forschungsteam hatte nämlich
herausgefunden dass männliche ratten
bestimmte tumore bekommen wenn sie
erstens dauerhaft zweitens mit hohen
dosen und drittens mit bestimmten
mobilfunk wellen bestrahlt werden doch
konkrete rückschlüsse auf den menschen
kann man durch solche eine studie eben
nicht ziehen anderen studien zufolge
sollen die effekte der
mobilfunkstrahlung verhindern dass der
menschliche körper schäden an der dna
repariert auch die widerstandsfähigkeit
gegen krankheiten lasse nach und das mit
fatalen folgen wie stoffwechsel und
fortpflanzungs funktionen eine
expertengruppe un expertengruppe
natürlich der whu kann 2011 zu dem
ergebnis dass mobilfunkstrahlung
möglicherweise krebserregend ist dazu
wurden alle bis dahin veröffentlichten
studien ausgewertet
dennoch gibt es eben keinen
100-prozentigen nachweis dass die
nutzung eines smartphones krebs
verursachen könnte eindeutig
nachgewiesen ist bisher nur dass die
hochfrequente felder eine thermische
also damen de wirkung haben denn
handystrahlung gehört physikalisch
gesehen zu den mikrowellen und diese
sind eben auch in der lage gewebe zu
erhitzen das kennen wir aus dem
mikrowellenherd dieser sogenannte
thermische effekt soll aber durch
grenzwerte eingeschränkt werden
kritikern und kritikern zufolge reicht
das aber noch lange nicht aus in der
schweiz gibt es beispielsweise deutlich
niedrigere
werte von mobilfunkstrahlung eine große
rolle spielt in diesem zusammenhang die
internationale kommission für den schutz
vor nicht ionisierender strahlung bei
ciena ip
denn sie gibt empfehlungen auf den
beruhen die grenzwerte demnach muss erst
alarm geschlagen werden wenn die energie
die mit der strahlung übertragen wird
mehr als 2 watt pro kilogramm
körpergewicht erreicht denn erst dann
ist die temperatur im gewebe messbar
also die erhöhte temperatur
doch ist das wirklich wirklichen
gefahren angemessen für die skeptiker
und skeptikerin ist zudem kurios dass
die svp stark mit den zuständigen
behörden verflochten ist das hatte ein
journalistenteam von invest europe erst
kürzlich aufgedeckt das bundesamt für
strahlenschutz jedenfalls geht nicht
davon aus dass 5g gesundheitliche
schäden verursacht denn bestätigte
anhaltspunkte für mögliche effekte
fehlen demnach können die radiowellen
die menschliche dna eben nicht
unmittelbar schädigen auch eine
indirekte schädigung beispielsweise sich
freie radikale konnte bislang nicht
bewiesen werden auf der anderen seite
gibt es aber auch keine beweise dafür
dass mobilfunkstrahlung völlig
unschädlich ist das sagt auch das
bundesamt für strahlenschutz und dieser
beweis wird wohl auch in zukunft weiter
ausbleiben denn wie sollten studien an
vielen menschen über einen langen
zeitraum hinweg für 5 g durchgeführt
werden die benutzung von wifi netzwerken
bluetooth und anderen alten standards
würde einem möglichen effekt
verschleiern forschungsteams bleibt
somit nichts weiter übrig als indizien
weiter amtieren und zellkulturen zu
sammeln und wir selbst können auch durch
einige verhaltensweisen vor zu viel
strahlung können uns schützen
beispielsweise in dem land über ein
headset telefonieren anschaut das handy
an den kopf zu halten oder aber das
handy nachts in den flugmodus
verfrachten also alle funkverbindungen
kappen vorsicht ist jedenfalls die
mutter der porzellankiste
einerseits gibt es funkwellen auch
mega-star schon mehr als 100 jahre und
scheinbar ist noch niemand dadurch
geschädigt worden andererseits gibt es
menschen denen beim telefonieren mit dem
mobiltelefon speiübel wird
mobilfunkfrequenzen verursachen krebs
ist handy strahlung gefährlich für
menschen anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar klicks und wenn es
noch nicht getan habt bis dann
da kann